was a big day for families across the
valley
as more kids went into school for the
very first date
thank you so much for joining us here at
4 30 i'm christian kosovos and
i'm kirsten joyce now we have some
private schools and charter schools that
also started today as well bianca holman
has more from legacy traditional charter
in north las vegas we're at legacy
traditional school in north las vegas
it's their first
day of class so much excitement here on
campus
i'm joined by natalie burgess the school
leadership here
so tell us it's it's a huge day it's an
exciting day teachers they came back
july 30th so
they're ready for students absolutely
we've been planning and preparing
and we are ready to go to have everybody
back today
and some things you're bringing back
extracurricular activities i can't
imagine doing music and art through zoom
but now kids have that hands-on
experience absolutely we have a really
strong music program and arts program
here on our campus
and our teachers are really excited to
be able to bring that back for our
students
for sure i remember some of the plays
and musicals that were
online it's just not the same but uh you
all have been helping
students and families you know from
their mental health and helping them
through the pandemic
through financial on you know uneasiness
for a lot of families and giving them
food
and things like that really supporting
them absolutely we've really been
communicating to families how important
it is
that we're here for them we're here for
their children both
emotionally socially and yeah everybody
gets
free breakfast and free lunch and it's
been a great thing yeah you know if
you're hungry you're not going to be
able to learn so that's good that those
bellies are going to be full
and cleaning protocols kind of touch on
that how are you all implementing those
cleaning protocols yeah we have a really
strong custodial crew here on our campus
ensuring that all classrooms are clean
and ready to go daily
and our teachers follow all of our
mitigation policy as well in terms of
washing hands and ensuring that
kids are safe and ready to learn all
right so your message to families and
parents on the first day of school
we are so excited to have you back and
we can't wait to have a great year this
year
all right thank you so much and again
happy first day of class for all of our
students
across the valley reporting from north
las vegas bianca holman
8 news now